-Jabari, you are up next.
Pull the mic to spin the wheel
and see what
you'll be playing tonight.
-Okay. Oh, I do.
-Yeah, good luck.
-Let's do it, boys!
Oh, here we go!
[ Beeping, audience cheering ]
-Opposites Attract.
-Okay.
-♪ This is [indistinct] ♪
♪ Opposites Attract ♪
-Now, for this challenge,
you're gonna get two songs with
opposite words in their titles.
You have to sing the lyrics
of one of the songs
over the music of another song.
-Okay.
-Let's see what song you get.
[ Beeping, audience cheering ]
Ha!
-Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're gonna be singing
the lyrics of "Yeah!",
okay, to the tune of "No Tears
Left to Cry," Ariana Grande.
Do you know --
Do you know "Yeah!"?
-Yeah.
-What?
Yeah? Alright, here we go.
Usher, Ariana Grande
together at last.
Band, let's hear it.
-Let's go, Jabari.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Up in the club
with my homies ♪
♪ Trying to get a lil' V-I ♪
♪ Keep it down on the low-key ♪
♪ You should know how it feels ♪
-Hey!
-♪ I saw this shorty,
she was checking up on me ♪
♪ From the game
she was spitting in my ear ♪
♪ You would think
that she know me ♪
-♪ Know me ♪
-♪ I decided to chill ♪
-He's singing it.
-♪ Conversation got heavy ♪
♪ She had me feeling like
she's ready to blow ♪
-♪ Watch out ♪
-♪ Oh ♪
-♪ She's saying, "Come get me" ♪
♪ So I got up
and followed her to the floor ♪
♪ She said, "Baby, let's go" ♪
♪ That's when I told her ♪
♪ I said, "Yeah!" ♪
♪ Shorty got down low
and said, "Come and get me" ♪
♪ I got so caught up,
I forgot she told me ♪
♪♪
♪ Her and my girl
was the best of homies ♪
-♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
-♪ Next thing I knew,
she was all up on me screaming ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
-It's like he's done this
before.
-It is!
-♪ Yeah ♪
-Like he's done this before!
♪ Yeah ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my goodness!
What?!
-I don't know.
-You make it look easy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You make it look easy
right there! Alright.